hoặc mùi một sự ngày 2018, sau năm 2018, trong khoả trình tôn chá, kìm sất trên tuyền của lộ 20 mũi, tổ công tắc số 2 thục quan cạnh rất sợ thông công an庭 phủ hành lỗi phát hiện xe autododeu
kéo kéo theo Somi dưới móc có giấu hiệu kinh nửi tích thích thành tủ xe. Tổ công tắc đã già hợi lệ yêu cầu dân functện để kìm chá,
tên yên, lại xe không chức thành giữ lệ mặt tăng tốt bỏ trậy. Lừng lượng cạnh rất sợ thông đã bang theo, lên tục xửu loa phát hiện hiệu yêu cầu dân xe.
Đến khu hục đường bún trong 20 bẩy tại xe mới cho bánh dừng phương kịch.
Qua kiểm tra tại xe được sau lệ lần Xe P,
sinh năm 1877, chú tại Hanoi,
tại xe P không có dễ phép lại xe phu hợp với loại xe đang điều khiến.
Phương kịch thức thủng xe không đúng với thông số kỹ thật ký trong xe chính hiện kinh định
ăn toàn kỹ thật và bảo vệ mua chương.
Kiểm tra nừng độ quần và mắt đuy đối với lại xe cho kỹ quả âm tính.
Tên cứ hình vì vì phạc, lội kể xe cho thông đường bộ số nguyễn đã lập biến bản sự phạt đối với tại xe nở xe P,
đông thời là chú phương kịch với các vì phạc.
Lưa phương kịch có kỹ thức thủng xe không đúng với thông số kỹ thật.
Không có xe phép lại xe cho kỹ định.
Không trước hành giữa lệnh của mình kiểm soát xe sau thông.
Tổng mức sự phạt là xong mới bẩy chự động.
Mà những thức sự phạt tiền, lựa lượng chức ngang còn tạm giữ phương kịch và bộ chú phương kịch
hơi phục lại kỹ thức thủng xe cho đúng quy định trước khi tiếp tục thăm xa sau thông.